three
two
one
zero
let's begin with the simplest of space
math
from 1960 to 2020 the number of
satellites in orbit increased at a slow
and steady pace
we went from zero satellites to about
2500 satellites
zipping by
over our heads
by the end of 2021 however that number
had doubled to five thousand
and this is not an anomaly
five thousand will soon turn to ten
thousand and then
deep breaths a hundred thousand
satellites if companies like spacex
amazon and many others get their way
most of these satellites will settle in
low earth orbit which is right here
it might seem like a roomy enough place
but it's already filled with those
existing satellites leftover rocket
bodies and debris from collisions
in some countries
have only made matters worse
by firing missiles into space
and blowing things up
what we have here is a real problem
the kind of problem that could ruin
space now and for many years into the
future
if only someone somewhere was doing
something about it
[Music]
[Music]
today i am gonna go visit a company
called leo labs it's a startup based
right here in silicon valley
you can think of them as a sci-fi super
modern air traffic control system
they've built some technology that
tracks everything in space
rocket bodies that have gone up there
satellites all the debris from things
that have collided and exploded
it's kind of an essential technology
that we're going to need in the coming
years as space fills with more and more
stuff
and so i'm gonna head into their office
and try and figure out how this
technology works
[Music]
the core of what we do is tracking all
the satellites all the pieces of debris
in low earth orbit and the reason we're
in business is space has gone into space
race 2.0 and so the numbers of
satellites are scaling up the risk from
debris is scaling up none of the
tracking systems were built to scale
and the reason we started the company is
because we knew how to build scalable
tracking systems so we're in the process
of doing that
dan and his co-founders started leo labs
in 2015
and they appeared just in the nick of
time
the success of elon musk's spacex
triggered a revolution in the space
industry
almost out of nowhere the world became
awash in rocket and satellite startups
more people than ever before want to put
more stuff than ever before
into orbit
the leo labs founders saw this frenzy of
activity coming
and they bet that we would soon need
better systems for tracking things in
space
you guys were ahead of the game in kind
of predicting where
this economy was going yeah that's the
whole reason we're in business the
number of satellites has gone up so
dramatically we focus on low earth orbit
so kind of the closest 2 000 kilometers
to the surface of the earth
that's where the revolution in space is
happened it's where the business
revolution is
three years ago there were 800
functional satellites in that part of
space now there's close to 4 000 on top
of that there are about 15 000 pieces of
debris tracked today dead satellites
dead rocket bodies and fragments of it
and there's been weapons tests there's
been collisions
on top of those 15 000 pieces of debris
there's about 250 000 critical but
untracked pieces of debris up there
today so a big part of what we've set
out to do is track that small stuff and
bring it into the safety picture
[Music]
to date leo labs has raised more than
100 million dollars
a lot of that money is going toward the
construction of a network of radars
placed around the world
it's these radar systems that look up at
the sky and spot and catalog objects as
they orbit
you need this global network of radars
if you've got one radar site you can
check in on a satellite about twice a
day so every 12 hours okay that's a long
time to wait yeah really you need sites
around the world you know we've got four
sites today we're going to more than 20
sites over the next few years so today
you guys are in like midland texas costa
rica alaska and new zealand is that's
right okay yeah and then we've got three
more sites under construction a big part
of leolab's mission is not just tracking
objects in space but actually making
sure that satellites don't collide into
each other satellite companies like
spacex and planet labs
pay to find out where their satellites
are
and if they're about to hit something
a lot of the satellites have propulsion
systems they can kind of move to get out
of the way of each other or change their
orbit a little bit it's a service that
you guys offer to help these companies
know how to maneuver their machines yeah
we offer a collision avoidance service
it's a subscription service we'll send
you an alert up to seven days in advance
if your satellite's going to come
dangerously close to a piece of debris
or another satellite
and most satellites have a thruster on
board a chemical rocket or an electric
thruster companies have been doing that
for decades moving satellites around but
it's sort of like a harder problem now
the risk of a collision is a lot higher
now
just because we've installed so much
more hardware into space
you have a big collision it creates a
cloud of debris and now all the other
satellites are flying through this
whizzing mess
of debris
the other element of it is the need for
tracking all the small debris as well as
we add all of the new satellites into
space the risks of the collision the
likelihood of the collision is going up
right now we're putting out about 400
million
collision alerts per month okay in low
earth orbit so these are either the
first alert of collisions happened or
follow-ups letting you know 400 400
million million okay what does that mean
you're setting up 400 million like uh
emails or
you can get them over email that's kind
of the legacy way of doing it it's
machine to machine so we push out these
alerts through our api
and then the satellite operators these
days their fleets are automated so when
we send them an alert they can decide to
nudge their satellite again or at a
different time to avoid the collision
to really understand how the leo labs
service works it would be super helpful
to have an astronaut
someone who spent time aboard the
international space station dodging
debris on a daily basis
and
as luck would have it i found just such
a human
i'm ed lew i'm one of the co-founders of
leo labs and you are an astronaut i am a
former nasa astronaut i flew three times
in space two times on the space shuttle
then i launched on a soyuz mission to
iss immediately following
the columbia
disaster when you're on the iss
you guys actually do get pelted by
debris right yeah things do hit the iss
i remember looking out on the solar
arrays and
you can see holes in them in fact i
remember doing a spacewalk coming down a
railing and there's a thing that looked
like a bullet hole in one of the uh
railings so it literally hit a railing a
steel railing was it
experiences like that that
drew you to this
startup or how did you end up getting
involved with leo absolutely so
at the time the number one danger to
crews on iss
uh was orbital debris
and to this day it is the number one
danger according to nasa's own figures
and
the reason is because the vast majority
of objects that are large enough to go
through the hull should they hit the iss
were not tracked or are not tracked by
the us government
and so this company was created to
track those
the vast majority of objects
smaller than our tracked
by the department of events and because
they're danger not only to the
astronauts but to all of development of
low earth orbit
[Music]
as both dan and ed mentioned russia made
the space issue all too clear last year
it fired a missile at one of its own
satellites because
well because it could
and now everyone has been left to deal
with the consequences
so what we're looking at here is the
earth
and these are leolabs radars are
tracking the orbit of this
satellite cosmos 1408 was roughly along
this line and when you break it up
everything else kind of ends up
following that path that's why all this
stuff is kind of looking like this so
these are all the objects we're tracking
whenever any one of these things goes
through one of these beams we we
recalculate its orbit each of these uh
beams can track about two thousand
objects per hour you've got the green
are our actual satellites
yep the yellow or rocket bodies yep and
the red is debris yep and then blue is
unknown okay yeah it's important that
you put
your radars all around the earth because
that's how you get the coverage you want
to get to the southern hemisphere and
that's because while objects they spend
half their time in the southern
hemisphere and historically
people have left their trash up there
so those are the dead things the largest
of the current constellations is
starlink they are covering the earth in
these things there's more than 2 000 of
these things already and they're
launching them in groups of 60 every
couple of weeks
this is a big problem for satellite
operators when they launch and one of
these rockets spits out 30 40 50 100
satellites which one is there yeah right
because they're they're not all late
right so one of the services that we've
been providing commercially to companies
is hey figuring out which one is which
like if you look at this particular
picture you'd be like oh we're already
this place is jam packed but these
objects are very misleading yeah so
these are much larger for the purposes
of display again something that's the
size of you know china right yeah yeah
you know the size of a satellite is
gonna be really small it'd be less than
a pixel you couldn't see it okay so keep
in mind that there's a lot of satellites
up there there are many many thousands
of satellites but they're not this big
while myspace math is simple this space
math is hard
it takes brainiac people like bonnie
here to find out when satellites might
collide
as an astro person i get to work on
algorithms and those algorithms are
what's gonna go into the
you know server and it's gonna produce
some sort of alerts and the alerts are
the cdm so the conjunction data messages
the heart of the algorithm is
math and physics we have two satellites
in orbit and we know
the path and when they come to our radar
we get an approximation for position and
velocity so we know how fast these guys
are going and you know where they're
gonna go
if we have two of them going on a
collision course then we run something
that is called like the probability of
collision method which is going to tell
us hey
at what exact time these guys are going
to come close and how far off they're
going to be
one of the things that you can see like
the work that i do right now is going
into the safety of flight and looking
for conjunctions so if you are a solar
operator you know the name of your
satellite so you can just type it here
in object one
and then if you suspect that you might
be colliding with like another satellite
that you already know so for example i
don't know one of the starlinks from
spacex or one of the dopes from planet
or anything you could just type the
other object here in search
let's just say that you have no idea and
let's just say that you are me
a colombian citizen
that is trying to find out what's going
on with the one and only colombian
satellite that we have in orbit let's
look it up so we go faksa
and there he is we're just going to see
what's coming around factside so we do
search
and we have a potential collision with a
starlink and you can see when that is
going to happen in the future we can
click on view and it's going to take us
to a page that is called analysis report
it's going to show you the ground
station so you can see what the path is
that the two satellites are actually
following so it tells you the exact time
when we think it's going to collide it
gives you the missed distance and so you
know 20 kilometers in space is nothing
like nothing at all and so the actual
collision probability is actually low
yeah and so we know it's not like super
high risk
[Music]
without this type of work space runs the
risk of becoming unusable humans will
have messed up low earth orbit
in much the same way that we messed up
planet earth
this debris is a big issue there's this
thing called uh the kessler syndrome i
think it's what they call it right is
that yeah syndrome the right uh yeah
it's the catheter syndrome tell me how
that works i mean it's this idea of kind
of cascading debris clouds right yeah
the idea almost like a nuclear chain
reaction of one piece of debris hitting
another piece of debris and a cascade
i don't think we're close to an overall
risk of leo going into that
there are bad neighborhoods in space
though and so in effect we're becoming a
space realtor we can tell you where the
bad neighborhoods are and where the good
neighborhoods are
between about 800 and 900 kilometers
altitude there's been some bad events
there's been weapons tests where a
satellite was blown up uh there's been
uh breakup events and the like so
there's just there's more debris there
so if you're going to put out new
satellites you're going to launch these
satellites don't put them there put them
in other regions of space
the situation's manageable right now but
we do need to manage it better there's
satellites going into all different
orbits you see them going north south
and south north and kind of east west
and everything in between
and it's just not organized with a bit
of organization it can
i think we can put a lot more satellites
into space
we've seen
spacex with its starlink communication
system they want to put up something
like on the order of like 10 000 or more
satellites and they're not alone there's
multiple companies and countries that
want to put up tens of thousands of
satellites for coms networks and all
sorts of things and so
if everybody gets their wishes and
there's a hundred thousand satellites in
low earth orbit like
is that actually feasible to manage if
we have the right technology
i think we can totally manage it okay
that's the exciting part about this
second space race is it's commercial the
leaders in it are bringing
new commercial services to market and
they're leveraging new technology it's
moore's law brought to space
like you said
five ten years ago you'd spend ten years
designing and building a satellite you'd
run it for 20 years and so at the end
your technology would be 30 years old
and now uh companies are refreshing
their satellite design every year
launching their satellites every year
it's like keeping up with the latest
iphone i mean you're getting new new
chips new sensors new cameras all the
time exactly new cameras new computers
new radios it's awesome to me we're
building like a computing shell around
the earth to sort of analyze it in ways
we
never have before whether it's
photographing what's happening with the
rainforest and water and the movement of
people and roadways or the communication
systems it's kind of like this new
internet
layer around us that's how i think about
it
yeah i think about it the same way it's
it's uh and another way to look at is
business on earth is just stepping into
space in a big way for the first time so
now just normal day-to-day stuff's
getting routed through space and that
means it's communications networks
cameras yeah everything you said this is
the computer revolution in 1990
happening in space yeah the monitoring
and understanding of where everything is
and where it's going is going to be
crucial to the development of this
economic sphere
[Music]
you